I got a nasty TMI so what did it say I'm
gonna coach you next do you guys believe
that nonsense so the story is I saw it
what are you believe it well I think
it's come what there's a couple of
possibilities I think so this guy runs a
Twitter account called killer OJ Simpson
believe it or not at killer OJ Simpson
is not the official OJ count that we
were talking about yesterday but an
account that is marked parody and on
Twitter you can have parody accounts
they allow parody accounts especially if
it says parody and so you know he does
all kinds of stuff as if he's OJ Simpson
talking about killing Nicole Brown
Simpson whatever and he posted a video
yesterday to prove that it was real
quote-unquote they had gotten DMS from
one or enthrall James Simpson and it was
OJ saying you better stop your account
here do you want you want to play the
video the guy you can hear the guys
voice over in it and he made a video
because obviously if you just post
screenshots you can fake to make really
easily this could be a DM deep fake
video when we're looking at in the video
is he's showing his computer screen and
he's showing a DM window and it does
appear to be a typical Twitter DM window
and the account does appear to be the
real oj 32 can you go back home i can
get a clearer view of what the the at is
it possible that he put a 0 i was
thinkin something that were instead of a
real it was re a one is there one of
those little weird things like that's
that's a good call so what you know what
I bet you nailed it I'll bet the AL cuz
the O is an oh I'll bet the L in real is
a capital I maybe but that's exactly how
he did it cuz then he couldn't go
through to the Twitter account but then
he goes to the Twitter account shows
all his followers oh yeah he does click
oh he does okay let me sit yes click
through all right Lu this we're
detectives today is where it sets again
notice we're not detectives
we're just we're internet dicks yeah but
there was here's the thing there's a lag
there's a second lag there's a lag go
back a little bit watch he acknowledges
the lag but there is a lag there's a
weird click and it was it almost looks
like he pops open another window because
he's filming with his iPhone but you
can't see where the mouse goes very
possible see me come on computer there
you go this no I think this is fake I
think that he is done I just read I
think he is done - right now they're
showing him click through where he's
clicking on that and then all of a
sudden the mouse disappears come on
computer but you don't see him tabbing
over he's not tabbing over oh I seen a
boom yeah cuz it's in the corner see oh
it jumps to the next one I don't believe
it right I know I'm yeah ring with you
yeah he took his mouse and he opened up
another window yeah I absolutely don't
believe it can you try on Twitter right
now to get the account or the arm
looking right now to see if it's an
account the are e a I owe ya 32 I don't
see it listed as yeah they're just
they're just it's yep nope here's the
account and it looks like his except
it's only about thirteen point six
thousand followers this one has 14
followers and that's the real oj there
you go that's how you do the one no no
no no it's no no is that what yeah yeah
yep not with a one but with an i oh I'm
sorry
yep that's how I think he did it - yep
yep we figured it out Jim we cracked the
case we certainly did
so it's nonsense Jim it's ham internet
dicks that's right yeah that's right if
there's a problem these two big dicks
will solve it
right one more Jim and Sam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the SiriusXM avid